Senator Chuck Schumer has announced he's
voting against one of president Trump's
judicial nominees of course that's his
right to do that
Schumer I believe the nominee who's
named Marvin Quattlebaum is unqualified
for the job he might disagree with quad
Obama's judicial philosophy he could
simply oppose every nominee Trump makes
to the courts that's fine but Schumer
didn't pick any of those reasons for
opposing Quattlebaum instead he said
he's opposing the nomination because
Quattlebaum is the wrong color for real
watch the nomination of Marvin
Quattlebaum speaks to the overall lack
of diversity and president from
selections for the federal judiciary mr.
Quattlebaum replaces not one but two
scuttled Obama nominees who were African
American the Trump administration like
in so many other areas is taking a giant
step backward this time when it comes to
diversity of their nominations I'll be
voting no on the Quattlebaum nomination
so he shouldn't have the job because
he's the wrong color
you thought this principle was settled
50 years ago but on the left it isn't
and never has been treating people
differently just because their skin
color is wrong and reducing people to
members of their race is wrong
it's a cul-de-sac by the way and leads
to the worst most divisive in the end
most violent kind of politics Chuck
Schumer's apparently a throwback to the
Democrats to the segregation era sadly
he's not the only one